was bedeutet aktuell eigentlich noch
vollständig geimpft also das bedeutet
dass man einen sehr guten schutz hat vor
corona schwer zu erkranken oder gar
daran zu versterben
aber was wir sehen es wenn diät diese
vollständige impfung also zwei impfungen
aller regel aus arbeitet sonst & johnson
länger
warum es sehen wir immer mehr im
durchbrüche gerade bei älteren und
deshalb ist boostern also auch die
dritte impfung wahrnehmen nicht etwas
muss man vielleicht mal machen sollte
sondern wenn das halbe jahr um ist wenn
man älter ist sollte man unbedingt sich
jetzt und reboots deswegen frage ich den
bis vor kurzem war das ja völlig
unstrittig und auch bei ihnen in der
region regierung ganz anders
kommuniziert er bedeutete vollständig
geimpft nämlich zwei fixe außer johnson
johnson einfach zweimal geimpft das ist
nicht mehr so vollständig geimpft
bedeutet nicht zweimal geimpft sondern
erst mit booster bei solchen großteil
unserer bevölkerung ist ja sozusagen
erst im juni juli mit der impfung
überhaupt fertig gehören deshalb gilt es
für die meisten noch aber wir haben im
januar angefangen das heißt es gibt
hochbetagte in altenpflegeeinrichtungen
und so bett für dies ist ja schon fast
ein jahr her zehn monaten seitdem gilt
eben nicht zweimal games bedeutet
vollständig und da sehen wir gerade auch
durch studien aus israel da ist es ganz
wichtig dass man nochmal auffrischt
damit man auch nicht nur eine kleine
grund immunität hat eine zelluläre
sondern damit man auch antikörper hat
wenn man mit einem infizierten kontakt
hat dass das immunsystem sofort reagiert
warum haben sie das eigentlich in der
regierung nicht gleich gesagt dass eine
dritte impfung nötig werden könnte das
eben zweimal gm nicht vollständiger
schutz bedeutet also dass mich ehrlich
gesagt auch müssen irritiert ist wir
haben im august in der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz von bund
und ländern vereinbart dass diese dritte
booster impfung erforderlich ist und
erst jetzt wo die zahlen steigen merken
alle welche welche
dringlichkeit da dahinter steht ich
wünsche mir dass wir wirklich jetzt in
den nächsten tagen und wochen sehr
schnell aber dass in dem pflegeheim mit
dem bus dann abschließen sie selbst sie
haben wir es immer gewusst dass es eine
dritte impfung wahrscheinlich irgendwann
brauchen wird ja also wir haben schon im
sommer hinweise bekommen dass die dritte
impfung ähnlich gut vertragen wird wie
die zweite die sorge dass haben ja
manche gespürt die erste impfung war
nicht so schlimm die zweite war
unangenehm und jetzt haben sie sorge die
dritte vertrag ich dann gar nicht mehr
und da sein zeichnen die studien ein
anderes bild und deshalb haben wir auch
im august schon gesagt gerade die
älteren sowie die stiko das jetzt auch
im 4 müssen nach dem halben jahr zur
brust wann haben sie das gewusst dass
viele das ältere das vor erkrankten eine
dritte impfung brauchen werden dass
gepustet werden muss man soll ja im
august hat sich die
gesundheitsministerkonferenz dazu
eingelassen und dem kontext haben wir
uns auf dem weg ging im august da wurde
ja längst gebucht hat den israel zum
beispiel sie haben israelische studien
karte genannt ist ihnen das nicht
peinlich dass sie immer israelische
studie nennen müssen und keine eigenen
haben weil israel eben immer schneller
war nein das ist eigentlich war ja so
dass beyond eck und kaiser ein kleines
land wie israel sehr schnell voll
versorgt haben mit impfstoff dass wir
mit der ganzen europäischen union so
schnell nicht gegangen und deshalb ist
es doch für uns gut zu sehen zu lernen
aus anderen ländern und ich glaube wir
haben ihn wir haben unsere versprechen
dass wir im sommer jedem einen
impfangebot erster und zweiter peaks zu
machen gehalten haben und wir haben
jetzt die unglückliche situation dass
wir wirklich genügend impfstoff haben
für erst und zweitwohnungen und auch für
booster impfung aber dass immer noch 17
millionen erwachsene deutsche die erste
und zweite impfung nicht wahrnehmen
möchten und dass auch der booster noch
viel zu langsam anläuft weil auch viele
glauben dass der schutz der erst im
zweiten wenn sie hoch betagt sind
ausreicht sind sie überrascht sind sie
auch enttäuscht von der wirkung des
impfstoffs dass sie so schnell schon
wieder nach impfen müssen in so großen
teilen der bevölkerung das ist ein super
impfstoff wir haben in früheren jahren
über impfstoff qualität über
wirkungsgrad prozent über sterile
immunität börse im durchbrüche ja
überhaupt nie gesprochen und wenn wir
klassische impfungen wie den
grippeimpfstoff daneben stellen dann
sieht man schon dass gerade unsere m rna
impfstoffe bei krone die retten uns ja
das problem dass wir jetzt im herbst
haben dass wir sehen das gerade in den
bundesländern niedrigere impfquote jetzt
auch die krankenhäuser voll laufen also
schwere verläufe das ist ja unser
eigentliches problem nicht leichter
sondern schwerer verläufe das entsteht
da wohl nicht geimpft ist dass der
impfstoff super die leute sind gut
geschützt und wenn alle geschützt werden
hätten noch keine schweren verläufen
aber offenbar sind sie oder sind weite
teile der regierung der politik ja schon
zunehmend überrascht davon wie sehr
diese pandemie jetzt auch geimpfte
trifft hatte ich zumindest den eindruck
in einer video-konferenz von sachsens
ministerpräsident kretschmann unter
anderem mit dem chef der uniklinik
leipzig schauen wir mal kurz rein
und ich dann 18 intensivpatienten sind
acht die impfte
und bei der normalstation ist sogar
größere anteil von geimpften als nicht
geimpften das heißt auch die geimpften
stellen und das wir haben auch
artikuliert worden eine nicht
unerhebliche gefahr dar eine frage die
mir hängen geblieben ist sie sagten sind
auf der normalstation mehr geben müsste
es um
gmbh naja ist ja schon überrascht nein
aber das war hatten wir auch in
großbritannien übrigens vor einigen
monaten sondern gesagt hat hälfte hälfte
sind geimpfte ungeimpfte auf den
stationen wie kann das denn sein aber
wir müssen immer sehen die gruppe der
geimpften in unserer gesellschaft ist
viel viel größer und wenn ein anteil von
denen und der die impf wirkung das
stimmt die ist nicht 100 prozent aber
die ist je nach altersgruppe ist die
wirksamkeit 80 bis 90 prozess ist auch
kein plädoyer ging es überhaupt nicht
die frage ist nur sind sie überrascht
davon wie sehr diese pandemie jetzt
wieder in diesem herbst im nahen den
winter eben auch geimpfte trifft nein
das war zu erwarten dass wenn man diese
diese zahlen kennt die haben wir auch
immer berechnet wenn man von einer
90-prozentigen impfquote also im erfolgs
quote das schwere verläufe angeht
ausgeht muss man sagen auch zehn prozent
häufig die älteren häufig die schwerer
vor erkrankten werden trotz der impfung
einen verlauf haben der möglicherweise
auch ins krankenhaus führt und wenn ein
großer teil der bevölkerung geimpft ist
dann kann man auch die zahlen derer im
krankenhaus nicht vernachlässigen das
ist völlig klar dann haben sie uns doch
erst vorgemacht wenn sie gesagt haben
das ist eine pandemie die an gm
sommer im herbst es ist keine pandemie
der ungeimpften das ist wieder eine
pandemie aller das ist auch eine
pandemie der gf nein so würde ich es
nicht sagen weil wir müssen zwei dinge
auseinanderhalten auf der einen seite
einen hohen schutz sie als zweifach
geimpft haben eine um 90 prozent
reduzierte gefahr dass sie ins
krankenhaus müssen sie nehmen an der
pandemie viel weniger sie haben eine um
über 80 prozent reduzierte gefahr dass
sie sich selber überhaupt anstecken und
einen anderen anstecken könnten das
heißt um um den vier von fünf die
geimpft sind neben an der pandemie nicht
teil aber einer vielleicht doch und
deshalb haben wir auch gesagt dieses
risiko können werden der gesellschaft
akzeptieren wenn wir alle geimpft wären
würde das dazu führen dass es nur wenig
infizierte und keine probleme in den
krankenhäusern gebe das problem das wir
nicht akzeptieren können ist dass die
ungeimpften hat alle zu 100 prozent in
dem anime stehen jedes risiko haben das
volle risiko ins krankenhaus zu kommen
das volle risiko
überträger zu werden das volle risiko
für einen schweren verlauf sie habe
gerade das schneckentempo das deutsche
schneckentempo beim booster impfung
schon angesprochen es war ich habe mir
das hier noch mal aufgeschrieben am 6.9
erst dass sich die gesundheitsminister
der länder
ausgesprochen haben für diese booster
impfung für alle die über 60 sind dann
direkt danach
einige wochen danach hat ihr
gesundheitsminister also jenen sparen
gesagt diese booster impfung solle
kommen für alle ab 12 jahren also eine
andere altersgruppe dann haben ärzte den
iren sparen dafür scharf kritisiert
jetzt beginnt gerade in diesen tagen die
stiko erst mit dieser prüfung der frage
ob man boostern für alle empfehlen kann
die entscheidung wird in wenigen wochen
fallen sagt die stiko das ist doch alles
ein witz nein die stiko hat einen sehr
klaren auftrag nämlich
risikoabwägung auf der grundlage von
ganz klaren wissenschaftlichen daten zu
machen und dafür wenn ich der stiko
dankbar und die sollten wir auch ihre
arbeit machen lassen das heißt sie
empfiehlt für ältere die booster impfung
weil sie sagt da wissen wir heute 100
dass der vorteil für jeden einzelnen
wiegt
zugelassen ist der impfstoff aber für
alle erwachsenen auch für die dritte
impfung das heißt wenn ich sage ich
empfinde mein individuelles risiko als
so hoch weil ich sehr viele kontakte
habe weil ich besonders viele kunden
treffe das sich über träger werde das
möchte ich nicht dann kann man sich auch
individuell entscheiden
ich möchte die booster impfung auch
obwohl ich jünger bin gerne haben wenn
das halbe jahr um ist und das muster
arzt dann aufklären das ist nicht auf
der grundlage der stiko empfehlung ist
aber es ist zugelassen und es wird auch
bezahlt aber all diese unterschiedlichen
ansagen teilweise im tages abstand oder
nur mit wenigen wochen dazwischen mehr
hätte man doch die bevölkerung in der
frage auch gar nicht verunsichern können
oder das problem ist wenn man es mit
einer neuen erkrankung mit einem neuen
impfstoff zu tun hat muss man aus
erfahrung lernen und also bin ich ja
froh dass wir manchmal nach israel
manchmal nach großbritannien andere
länder gucken können wie verläuft die
infektion da wie verläuft das impfen
dort sind froh dass wir langsam sind
weil dann können die es uns vormachen
aber in der zeit passiert ja auch was
hier in der pandemie in deutschland das
heißt muss man sagen das kostet leben
das wir auch wieder beim boostern zu
spät sind das kostet gerade leben in den
alten heim also in den altenheimen ist
das was mich am meisten erschüttert muss
ich wirklich sagen dass wir immer gesagt
haben wir brauchen dort ein ganz enges
testen dort wird das testen übrigens
auch weiterhin bezahlt und bei einigen
der vorfälle letzten tage hört man dann
das jetzt ja wieder mehr getestet werden
soll in den altenheimen und das ist
etwas das kann ich nicht akzeptieren und
deshalb das können sich sehr dafür dass
wir eine gesetzliche testpflicht jetzt
fest schreiben dass wir das nicht nur
verordnungen überlassen sondern dass wir
klar sagen also das regelmäßig links
gemacht zu haben das nehmen sie auf ihre
kappe nein das ist etwas wo ich bisher
davon ausgegangen bin dass das erfolgt
jetzt sehen wir dass es nicht der fall
ist und ob es die anregung es nicht auf
der verordnungsebene sondern auf der
gesetzesebene zu regeln sie alle nicht
vorher mal nachgefragt passiert weil das
ist ja allen die eltern die oma und opa
im km im altenheim haben bekannt dass
das nicht gemacht wird ich habe letztes
jahr weihnachten als die situation sehr
schwierig war haben wir verstanden dass
es dort schwierigkeiten gibt und wir
haben dann die bundeswehr in die
pflegeheime geschickt und tests sondern
das ist das sensibelste thema sollte
dass wir das sterben in den pflegeheimen
wir weihnachten letztes jahr wenn nicht
wieder erleben und deshalb haben wir in
ganz regelmäßig jetzt immer in
gesprächen gesagt das testen muss
weitergehen das testen im pflegeheim
muss weiter bezahlt werden also ist
alles geregelt ich habe jetzt nur in den
letzten tagen wo die zahlen jetzt hoch
gehen sie waren im sommer in der alten
der älteren bevölkerung ganz niedrig wir
haben zum schulanfang wirklich gesehen
junge leute die sich infizieren niedrige
todeszahlen das war nicht das zentrale
problem das was wir jetzt sehen ist dass
in der altersgruppe über 80 über 90 die
infektionszahlen deutlich ansteigen die
todeszahlen ansteigen und deshalb
dritter booster für alle älteren und
konsequentes testen in den einrichtungen
das müssen wir jetzt machen und
nötigenfalls auch gesetzlich absichern
wollen sie nächste woche wieder am
liebsten zusammensetzen und die korona
regeln verschärfen zumindest für die
ungeimpften so sagen sie vorab so hat es
auch die kanzlerin formuliert dürfen sie
das überhaupt noch sie sind nur noch
geschäftsführend im amt sind sie
überhaupt noch zu stellen die für solche
weitreichenden gesellschaftlichen
eingriffe selbstverständlich denn die
geschäftsführung die bundesregierung hat
ein zurückhaltung gebot was neue
politische projekte angeht das was in
den nächsten jahren und deutschland
geschieht wird die neue bundesregierung
planen und ausführen aber die
bundesregierung hat bis zum allerletzten
tag alle rechte und pflichten
deutschland zu schützen und gefahren
abzuwehren und das was wir jetzt gerade
erleben wir haben ja warnungen aus
einigen bundesländern das sind zwei
wochen bereits eine tatsächliche
überlastung des kranken
versorgungssystems passieren könnte in
einer solchen situation kann nicht nur
da muss eine bundesregierung handeln und
das bis zum letzten tag das werden wir
auch tun letzte frage herr
kanzleramtschef wenn die pandemie
irgendwann hoffentlich vorbei ist wie
werden sie in der geschichte da stehen
sie und ihre regierung als große corona
versager oder als große corona helden
also ich glaube
wenn man eine solche naturkatastrophe
erlebt die
hunderttausende leben kostet dann gibt
es keine helden und das fände ich auch
falsch aber ganz viele helden in den
krankenhäusern natürlich nicht sie
kennen die aus ihrem früheren beruf das
stimmt also und auch die sollten wir in
diesen tagen denken wenn wir unsere
freizeit rechte sehen gegenüber der
belastung die ärzte und krankenpfleger
schon wieder im winter wie im letztes
jahr weihnachten jetzt erleben aber die
frage die in den geschichtsbüchern sich
stellen wird und vielleicht auch schon
viel früher als bevor ein geschichtsbuch
geschrieben und ist doch die frage ist
deutschland insgesamt gut durch die
krise gekommen und ich glaube wenn man
sich die über sterblichkeit an guckt
also wieviel krankheitslast wie viele
tote fordert die pandemie bis dato in
deutschland im europäischen vergleich
steht deutschland gut da und
wirtschaftlich grad noch zwei mal da
sind wir sehr viel besser durchgekommen
als andere insofern glaube ich dass die
bundesregierung ihre arbeit da sehr gut
gemacht hat aber was ist in einer
solchen naturkatastrophe trotzdem kein
grund zu jubeln das sagt der
kanzleramtschef vier heute bei blyth
danke für dieses gespräch